America has become land of the free and
home of the broke we live in the most
advanced Society with so much
opportunity and yet we have more stress
and less money than ever before make it
make sense one in four people said they
rely on credit cards to make ends meet
they got nothing in the bank and they're
hoping Capital one's going to save the
day 50% of people said they struggle to
pay their rent 38% said I struggle to
pay my mortgage nearly four in 10 people
have $0 in savings y'all one emergency
away from their life imploding and
here's what that leads to half of
Americans said they worry about personal
finances daily every day they wake up
that same lump in the throat that pit in
the stomach they get in their car they
go to the job they hate just hoping to
cover the bills this is no way to live
that's Bleak stuff